[Music]
uh hello everyone this is Victor
michelevsky from the Saint Louis chess
club
uh today I'm going to uh
show you uh
one of the ideas how to prepare for
tournaments and in this case it will be
studies
so sometimes when I want to prepare for
the tournament
I'm just solving studies
and it might be a good idea because it
helps with your calculation
helps to look for some original ideas
and today I'll show you some of the
studies of my own
and you can try to to solve them
so this might be a good idea to prepare
for tournaments anyway so the first
study is on the board
it's white to move and win
I'll correct some of them are difficult
we want those easy studies yeah
if it's too easy it's not too
interesting right
so why to move look for your ideas
so playing G7 is the first uh suggestion
and in fact
okay Captain ketchup says g798 and C7
check
that's a good idea
so let's
let's start Alex is also saying G7 so G7
is the correct
there is nothing else white can do
because after all white is down a queen
right
so we should try to promote the Zippo
uh black plays Knight 28 as was
suggested
another option is Knight D5 but it's
less interesting
so the G7 Pawn is pinned yeah
right so
we have to do something about it
and so C7 indeed
C7 check
so that's a good idea to block the
seventh rank with the check
what will black do now
yeah so uh blackened definitely take
this C7 Pawn with the Knight
but in this case the G Pawn will not be
pinned anymore right yeah
Yeah so basically uh black has two
options user he takes or he moves his
King away
there is nothing else
let's say first of all if black plays
King D7
by the way the move King said makes no
sense because then we just promote right
and
just to make it clear so uh King D7 if
you wanna move the king away
what should I do now
Rook H6 trying to stop the move Knight
F6
right but in this case black can
probably just take the pawn
uh if it promotes a g-pawn the Knight F6
check
and uh
you get back the queen
Rook C2 a very good idea in fact
so what is preparing the move C7 seat
so if if black takes the poem with the
Knight trying to stop the move seat then
we simply promote the Zippo
no checks and
white is going to win
another option for black would be trying
to stop the move seat with the queen
right so let's try something say queen
what do you do in this case
yeah very good so we promote the C Pawn
with the check Queen takes Rook takes
and if black takes the Rook
we just promote the G pawn and now the
Knight is pin so no Knight F6 check
if he takes the pawn instead
white should still be winning if he
plays Rook C7 check
and then after King D6 Rook G7
and in fact this is a win for weight
even though uh White should still win
here
like for instance the king may come here
and if we capture this Pawn on G4 which
is one of the options King G6 is also
possible black can try to
shoulder our king with a king
and then say Rook Jade D5
and now the only winning move
surprisingly skin gauge 6.
let's say if they go E4 we play King H5
King 4 King H4
the idea is to give a check right when
the Kinks are in this opposition like
say if they pushes three we play check
and bring the king so they should try to
go King F3
we continue advancing the king
down the board
so if they play a three again check
we can play Rook Cafe check first a very
important intermediate check
the king cannot go to G1 because then we
just win the pawn and if the King goes
this way we bring the king and win
easily
okay that's just one of the wins but uh
yeah white should still be a careful
after Knight takes too soon
so sometimes as you can see the studies
can also help you in your endgame
technique
not only in calculations
so let's come back to the position after
a C7 check
so we tried King D7 and it didn't work
because of Rook 2 C2
so now let's take with the Knight
so Alex says promote J2 is a check
what do you think
would that be a good idea
yeah that's right after Jay check 98 is
also a check
white will have to move the king let's
say to G6 right
to avoid checks but then black can play
Queen is three
and it's uh the a lot of checks are
coming and it's gonna be a draw in this
line
also black wants to win this Pawn
let's say we should check like this
but anyway there are a lot of checks and
so we should do something else
after Knight takes system
yeah
Rook A2
an interesting try so you want to
sacrifice your Rook but what if
what if black just takes
Captain ketchup also suggested through
K2
so just Queen takes you promote with the
checks the King goes to D7
Alex says G7 is nice it was suggested
first by
Fisher sip
D7 is a nice try but in fact that's your
last Pawn right so after D7 a white can
play uh still probably night to eat
maybe there is also some other move
probably even better after D7 to play
ah we can even take the pawn or play
first queen D4 and then take the pawn
because there are no pawns on the board
left
Hussein rahimov says C7 first
uh
what does it mean first because in the
starting positions the black snide was
on C7
so we couldn't really do it
okay Captain ketchup says King to G6
okay uh I believe this move is kind of
similar to the move G8 because then
black can still play 98 and after Jade
Queen play Queen D4 or queen is Queen E3
let's say and
we get the same position like after J
check
okay
okay that's interesting so
there is a suggestion to take DTX C7
so black has to recapture with the queen
right otherwise we promote the g-pawn
and now to play King G6 but if you play
King G6 black simply takes a rook
it would be nice right if the Rook
wasn't on H2
so Rook did to check
right to move the Rook away uh with a
check
so black has to stay on the back rank
with the King if he goes King C now it's
easy
then we go King G6 what you suggested
and there is no way to stop GT
right
but black doesn't want to make it easy
for us and play skin gate
if we play something like Kim h8 which
is
suggested by Hussein rahimov zenzi a g
Pawn can be pinned
right it's not so easy to promote
support
okay Captain ketchup has one idea he
wants to play Rook to A2 a very
interesting idea in fact white wants to
play rookie check and then promotes the
g-pawn
try to understand why this ID is not
working though
what can black do no
Queen B7
uh Queen B7 okay if still okay check
yeah you cannot really take
Hussein let's first look at this idea
and then we'll see your idea of rookie
2.
okay let's finish this one
black pushes the Jeep on okay but if
still we give a check
then what's going to happen
so we have to go to the seventh string
okay
and then say white promotes
maybe we we then give a discovered chat
by moving the thing so where are we
moving the king so
to F6 okay this makes it a little bit
complicated like King F6 just loses to
Kim Gage hit because we have no more
checks
right we can go to D6 instead and in
fact this position is a draw but it's uh
easier for black
to play instead of the move G Series
remove Queen B7
so why is this one better because then
in case of rookie check you still go to
E7
Jade Queen
now King F6 check and now look at this
diagonal
right when your queen was on C7 and you
played G3 you blocked the diagonal
baseball
and now they have to go white has to go
back and queen H1 check is coming and
white is in fact losing
right
yeah that's why they move through K2
doesn't work
even so it's a nice try
so there were also suggestions of
playing Rook 2 E2
um
might also be an interesting Trail let's
see
but black can even play a queen to F7
this time
because the g-pawn is still pinned and
queen H5 check is a big threat
okay another suggestion was to play Rook
2 F2
and this idea is similar to Rook A2
white wants to play Rook f8 check
followed by Jade
and black skin cannot get to F6 in this
case right
so it looks like a possible solution
but in fact black still has a defense
here
so the queen goes to B7
now after a cafe check King G7 King E7
sorry Jade Queen and now Queenie 4 check
and it turns out that white skin cannot
Escape checks
so let's say King gauge 6
Queen is three check or queen H1 which
is also possible King H5
Queen H3 check
King G5 Queen E3 check if white blocks
with Xerox and black has a movie E5
and the checks don't really help because
eventually this Rook will be lost
and if white doesn't play Rook F4 he
doesn't have any way to avoid checks
let's say here Queen G1 check if you go
to their file there is a check
so that's just the truth
or here Queen H1
right we have checks on H1 G1 if
necessary we'll give a check from F1
when the King goes to their file
and now there is a suggestion playing
Rook 2 B2 instead of Rook F2
let's look at this option
so after they move King to E8
we make a quiet move Rook to B2
in fact this move creates a similar
threat of Rook to B8
and this Captain ketchup says not many
moves left for black
right what is black going to do now
there are a lot of legal moves of course
but
not so many good moves
first of all now the idea of Queen F7
would wouldn't work right we would just
give two checks and get the queen
so it it wouldn't make sense
same about communism
so let's try some other moves
if the queen goes to D7 let's say
then we just give a check right
check we promote
King F6 check and then we move away no
more checks
so let's try Queen to A7 then
but in fact white can still play Rook B
check
the King goes to E7
we play Jade
King goes to F6 with a check once again
Kim gate shade and Black's queen and
king in fact blocked the
check on D4
no more checks
okay you may think the queen is pretty
good on C7 so why don't we push pawns
right so
no now The Rook is covered in H2 so you
can you cannot go there right
okay so Captain ketchup says the queen
has to stay on C7
so let's just push the G Pawn Yeah and
keep the queen on C7
what do you do now
still of course rugby check obviously
zero cannot be taken because of jade
getting the queen and winning
so black should try to go with the King
to E7
and we still promote the G Pawn
so now after King F6 the King still goes
to h8
and the funny part is that the G3 Pawn
stopped black from giving a check
right same happens if black pushes the
other Pawn
E5
then the E5 Pawn will stop this check
King F6 King h8 again no checks
so as it was already mentioned in the
chat
after the move Rook B2 blackheads and
zugz wank
no moves that's a very surprising
position when one Rook can dominate the
queen
okay there is a question why not King
did and did a good question
what do we do in this case now rugby
check doesn't work
you can just capture The Rook
and not really King C7
no like if now we play Rook uh The Rook
beat Queen takes
you promote what you're not going to win
right
there is a problem
yeah and black will have two points yeah
yeah so what does y do in this case
okay Lemmings says King to G6 and he's
right because now there is no way to
stop jid
and no checks
but not King 2 h8 because in this case
uh
black can play Queen E5 and pins upon
and we cannot win anymore
right so King G6 is a very precise move
in case of King did
so indeed the position after Rook B2 is
a succulent position
okay I believe we are done with this
study
thank you cap Captain so next position
is this one
it's way to move and make it drop
because white is down a piece
thanks Eric
so now think about this one
okay Eric says Rook A1 but blackened
just takes an item D7 in this case
and Block C Checkmate on f8
sorry I forgot to mention the previous
study was based on a uh on one study of
Kamina Andres salima
but their study had no solution
so I changed that study and made it
solvable
okay let me explainer says feels like
some stale Matrix
Maybe
but there are still a lot of piss on the
board
uh Pawn takes on G6
that's a move to consider but I believe
black is still going to take on D7
okay Knight F6 in fact is an interesting
try so let's have a look
uh basically White's ideas to trade all
the pawns right and then Rook versus
rook and Knight is a draw
so let's see if it's gonna work so black
takes
G takes
what should Blake do now
because we are going to trade all the
pawns with f takes G6
take on F5 you say yeah
yeah
um
that's right so we can just take Rook
takes F3
F takes G6 Rook takes F6 but it's not
over yet white can try to protect the
pawn then the idea is to move the king
away and still exchange the last ball
nine facts there are a few wins for
black
so let me show just one of them for
instance Knight to E6 we just bring the
Knight closer to the G6 spawn
black white can only track engage five
there are no other tries
the Knight goes to F4 check
King G5
otherwise black just wins the pawn for
free in fact black and still takes this
Pawn with the check but now at least
white has a trick white can click engage
for so if you take the Rook it's a still
mean but obviously you don't have to do
it you can play for instance Knight E6
and
black wings
right so that's why the move Knight F6
doesn't work in the starting position
yeah white is looking for a draw Captain
deep says Rook D1 looks like it might
hold but I don't think so frankly
because black can even take D7 and play
Knight f8 and save his G6 ball
so Captain ketchup says Knight takes C5
Rook takes c5f takes G6
okay and indeed Knight C5 is a very
serious
attempt
all right also Eric says Knight takes C5
so what what are blacks options indeed
taken on C5 is one of the options
that's for sure but does black have any
other options in this position
look at White's King
in deterrick 93 is possible
so black creates a shred of Checkmate in
one Knight takes F5
what are we going to do now
how do we escape from the checkmate
so taken on G6 is only way to do so
right
and then
what is Black's point
okay
with the Rook on H1 that's right trying
to win The Rook on H1 with Knight F5
check indeed
King H5 and Knight G3 check
so is it over now
yeah The Rook on H1 is lost
that's right
but it is a game lost
black
will have an extra look at that right
but the Knight on H1 is still alive
right
of course yeah it's an extra look if you
get it on the on an empty board
okay Captain ketchup says Kim gauge 6 to
X clamps let's see
so Knight takes H1 and then his
suggestion is Knight to E4 what do you
think about it
so this way black is attacking The Rook
so what's wrong with just taking the
pawn on F3
then just Knight F6 check
if the Kink moves suddenly white
promotes a g-pawn
so basically black has to capture
then G takes F6
and we force the exchange of the last
one
with the draw
okay so this is basically the main line
of the study
right but we also should see what
happens if black just takes back right
after Knight takes C5 we didn't see this
line
so let's see if black just takes
what should I do in this case
F takes G6 says Eric but then black can
play Rook to C6 opinions upon
so I am homeless on Wi-Fi it says Rook
B1 and this is a correct movement fact
white can still create a thread of a
checkmate
so black will have to stop this idea
somehow
if we play if black plays Rook seed we
can simply take the pawn no Rook C6
right and it's an immediate draw
so black should try to block it with a
bishop
while The Rook can still go to C6 in
case of f takes G6
so what what should I do now
okay there is a suggestion not to get
mated and that's a good idea
so indeed Knight takes a 5 is amazing
thread
so yeah Captain ketchup says Rook beat
and that's the correct move
so black has to block with the Knight
obviously blocking with the Rook makes
no sense why just trades Rooks and take
the a G6 Pawn so Knight C8 has to be
played
that's right Rook B8 is a must
but what do we do now
if say we push the F Pawn then we
probably get checkmated
right we can give up The Rook but this
is not a stalemate because we have we
have another F Pawn
right and then at the end we will be
checkmated again
so pushing the pawn makes no sense
so the only remaining tries to take
right
so F takes G6 and black plays Rook C6
pinions upon that's also the only try
for black
in fact it's not yet easy
dip says F5 meaning probably F4
yeah indeed F4 has to be played with the
idea of playing F5 next month
so now black has two captures on G6
right
so let's say if the Rook takes
we move the king back zero goes back to
C6 in order to protect the Knight and
then we play F5
and this position turns out to be draw
so black will be unable to win
for instance if they play like King G7
probably we can just give a check and if
Kim Gage 7 we have a check as well I
mean we can attack the pawn
after Rook B7 then we have G6 check
right still exchange on this Pawn
uh so let's see if they take on G6 with
the pawn
so black is ready to play King F7
followed by Knight E7 and then black
queens
so what should the why do then
uh deep says Rook to B7
um with the idea of Rook G7 but if Rook
B7 probably just King f8 preparing Rook
preparing 97
if the Knight is out white will be lost
that's right that's right F5 is the only
move
F5
black should take
and then G6 indeed
that's the only move again
so now let's see if Blake is trying to
push the F Pawn because not much is left
right in this case we can simply play
Rook to B4 attacking the pawn
if the pawn goes to F3 we put the Rook
behind the pawn
and then we can even bring the king and
take the pawn
and if black plays Rook took to F6 then
we play King G5 with a double attack
and Etc
so okay let me show you again the main
line though so the main line was Knight
takes 93 97 is similar
yeah the Knight still gets the five in
both cases
check Knight takes on H1 and now a very
important intermediate movement ID for
attacking the rook and bring in the
Knight to F6
after Rook F3 Knight F6 Blake is forced
to take and the pawns get exchanged
okay it's not such a long calculation
okay let's move on
this is our next position
this one looks very complicated because
there are
I composer study
Goku
so it's why to move and white needs to
escape with the draw even though he is
down a full Queen
but for many pawns right
for six Pawns
the position looks bizarre right but
there is a pretty clear way to draw
today I'm only showing you my own
studies
which I composed
yes Fisher to prepare you for for a
tournament but you can also solve
studies on your own
right and
you can find a lot of studies online
and also in books
thank you lemons player
so how can white try to save the game
here
he's down a queen the Knight only it is
also hanging
we cannot really promote our pawns
because there is this bishop on Jade
which is stopping everything
there is also a threat of Knight takes
E4 check
which is important
so all of this helps us to make the very
first move
so let's see if you have any ideas
okay there are suggestions of 95 King C6
E5 so let's have a look
so if white plays Knight E5 check
black simply takes King takes Eid
right
there is no follow-up because the F6 is
hanging now
there are no good checks D7 is covered
by the Knight
okay there is also a suggestion of
Bishop F5
thank you Jessica
so um yeah 95 is not going to work
so let's see other suggestions so
Captain ketchup suggested they move King
to C6
but the idea behind this move is not
entirely clear right because black can
say take the E8 at night
and then probably just take the pawn
it's not so clear what we have achieved
so another suggestion was to play E5 in
order to push the EPO
in this case once again black is going
to take King takes E8
and after the move
E6 94 check King E5 and now black can
play check on G5
forcing the king to e4s and taking this
Knight with the check and white is also
going to lose the F6 spawn wherever the
King goes like E5 D5 for this series
there is always a check which means the
pawn
for instance something like this
right or or like King D3 at least Queen
F5 taking the spawn probably there are
many more wins so E5 is not working
this position but there was a suggestion
to play Bishop F5
by Russell and cuckoo
and indeed this is a correct move so
what's the point first of all we are
protecting the E4 Pawn avoiding a check
on e4
so if black still takes we simply we
simply take back right
in fact we can oops
sorry sorry
uh
so yeah
so if in fact if black takes on e4 the
best move would be probably even a king
to D7
even though taking only four might still
be possible
because now uh black skink finds himself
in some
mating it
so uh Knight X E4 is not a problem for
white
in this position
yeah so that's a main line how about
just taking on E8
okay there is a suggestion to play
Bishop G6 check and then Blake is forced
to play King deed
what do we do next though
H7
he has Queen E7 checks so looks very
suspicious frankly
uh bro probably black takes F7
I assume it should be Queen E7 check
the King goes to C6
okay it's still uh
a little tricky here
uh probably Queen C7 check or maybe
oh even better I assume to play Bishop
takes G6 so after a f8 I know sorry this
is not a good idea Jade Queen and white
wins
huh it's not not so easy right
there should be some way for black to uh
to win here
let's say check check on B3
King C6
I still don't see a Checkmate here
there is a suggestion going Queen B7
check in this position maybe this is a
correct way
yes this this should be the way so King
B5 Bishop A7 check
to C4
now probably check from B3
King D4
is there a Checkmate sorry this should
be right 97 checkmate
okay finally
you found something so yes H7 uh still
not enough if you try F7 instead of H7
then Queen E7 King C6
check on E6 and now black can play even
a quiet move like King system
I believe this would be possible also
after age seven
and then black history attending with
this checkmate
not much what it can do about it
so in fact it turns out that Bishop G6
Bishop G6 check is the wrong move
so what is white going to do he is down
a queen and a minor piece
okay so the suggestion is to play H7 but
then in case of Bishop takes
Bishop takes Queen takes
F7 King takes F7
and J check
very good very good that's basically the
idea so white plays H7
black is kind of forced to take other
moves don't help
Bishop takes white simply takes back
so now a clear threat is to promote the
pawn
black takes Queen takes H7 there is an
option of Knight takes E4 but it also
doesn't help
and then white plays F7 check
it's important to start with this check
because if we start with Jade check
Queen takes and F7 black intake with the
queen and no Fork
right so we should start with the move
F7 forcing the king to F7 and then Jade
check
and now it turns out that uh
after boss king Jade and queen Jade
white has a fork
so let's let's have a look so queen
sheet
Knight H6 check King f8
Knight takes jid
King takes Jade
but black is still uh black is still two
pieces up
why is this a draw
yes
that's right so we can try King C6
attacking both pieces but the bishop
goes to A7 keeping the Knight protected
okay so there is a suggestion to play D4
and in case of Knight takes E4 King B7
trapping the bishop
right so indeed D4 is the correct move
and if black takes we do play King B7
trap in the bishop but black can try
Knight to A4
so now if you play King B7 Bishop B6 the
bishop escapes
D5
we have to see because black skin is
pretty close
so D7 maybe King f8
or King F7 not sure maybe King F7 as
well
a draw is not guaranteed
the chess weekends is suggesting E5 with
the idea of playing King B5 King gate 6.
and why is that enough
because at the end when the bishop goes
to beat we trap the bishop is King B7
right so basically after they move E5
the bishop cannot escape from there
right so the threat is to play King B5
then King A6 King B7 and the bishop is
trapped
so it doesn't matter where the King goes
King B5 let's say Knight C3 check King
gay sex Bishop beat king B7
the bishop is trapped and the white
achieves a drop
yeah yeah that's why the pawns were on
D2 is 3 and D4
to trap Black's Bishop
okay
um
let me give you uh one more puzzle even
though this one looks
difficult you know
um
okay let's do this one this is kind of
similar to the puzzle you have already
seen there's just a different version of
the same puzzle
it's again white to move and achieve a
draw
okay dips still wants to play a rook to
D1
and in fact this is a wrong move because
the Rook takes E3 and now black has a
set of Rook H3 checkmate
okay there is a suggestion playing C6
even though I don't really get this idea
if C6 black can at least take this
opponent
there is a threat of a Checkmate which
cannot be avoided
okay Rook B1 there is also suggestions
suggestion in the chat to play Rook B1
but this move is also uh doesn't work
for a very interesting reason black has
Knight a to B6
the point is that white skin is in the
meeting net
right so uh let's say we take with the
pawn
then black plays Knight takes E3
threading in with the Checkmate if we
play Knight F6 check King gate shade
Knight F5 is still a big threat if we
are trying to take this Knight with the
Rook the Knight F5 check Rook takes a 5
and Rook H3
and white still gets checkmated
so that's why the move Rook B1 also
doesn't work
and I am homeless on Wi-Fi says after
that first puzzle I assume it's F5 and
in fact you're right F5 is the first
move
so um
let's see what uh Black's options are so
if black takes G takes F5
he's even going to lose after Rook B1
because now there will be no checkmate
at the end
white will be able to play G6 and escape
with the King let's say after the move
Knight B6 we can probably just take
rookie 3 and
play G6
and only uh only black can be in trouble
here
so taking on F5 is not a good idea if we
take Knight takes C5
okay Knight C5 in fact is the main line
so let's see first if they play uh
Knight takes E3 here
like similar to similar to the previous
position yeah with the same idea
then we can also take F takes G6 Knight
F5 check
ing H5 Knight G3 check and we come back
to H6 so if Knight takes H1 same Knight
F6 check is coming so basically black is
forced to repeat moves
and so the main line is indeed Knight
takes C5 taking the pawn
so what do we do do we still take Knight
takes C5 like in the previous puzzle
dip says Knight F6 check
and why not Knight takes C5 this time
again
and in fact the problem is that now
after the move Rook after the move
Knight takes E3
F takes
Knight F5
King gauge 5 Knight G3 check
Kim gauge 6 Knight takes H1 and Knight
E4
black has a nice Checkmate Rook H3
in the previous case black white still
had a Pawn on A3 I believe or G3
so this is not the same position
right so that's why Knight takes C5
doesn't work and Knight F6 indeed is the
correct move so Knight takes F6
G takes F6
white is happy to exchange his last pawn
and so black should play G takes F5
so what do we do now
we are still down a piece and black has
a couple of Pawns left
Rook A1 indeed
creating a threat of rookie checkmate
so what should black do now
he doesn't have my choice right
97 or 96 yeah it doesn't really matter
black has to block the check on the
background increase the Knight
so we play check the Knight goes to f8
but we are still down a lot of material
right a full piece
yeah
a very good idea but black cannot make
progress so we are just going to take
this F5 Pawn to take our exchange if
necessary and black will be unable to
make progress because his Knight on the
back rank is pinned
so let's say if black plays Rook C5 we
can just play King of four there is no
way for black to unpin
so black should try to take these three
Pawn
y takes the F5 Pawn now only blacks
attempt to unpin is to bring this Rook
to h8 and play King H7
so let's try Rook H3
what should I do in this case
King 2e5 you mean
but if you play King D6 and the black
circus on the H file they can go like
this
I mean you can play King give 5 in this
position I believe
and then wait for the move through okay
chain and only then try King D6 but even
then you have to consider this type of
idea because the opponent game might be
lost
right so in fact the safest here is to
just wait with the King close to the
pawn
black plays through K shade
and we keep waiting with the King as
soon as they play King gauge 7 we play
Rook A7
attacking the F7 Pawn
and there is no other defense
but King Jade and then we just come back
to it
and there is no way for black to make
progress
okay I believe this will be it for today
uh thanks all for watching
and I'll see you all next week
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign